to introduce kita let me invite to the
stage a member of the Academy of Board
of Governors Oscar nominee Jennifer yuh
Nelson has spent many years directing
the last to the last two Kung Fu Panda
films and some years working on the
first one come to the stage let's
present when I read gita script dinner
with friends the first thing I thought
was well someone needs to make this
right now it's really good there's no
special effects in it it could be very
budgetarily done the second thing I
thought was how real the characters were
in this intimate portrayal of a complex
funny and dysfunctional immigrant family
it stayed away from the typical tropes
and allowed us to readers to peer into
real lives with real struggles and real
warmth it resonated with me because as
part of an immigrant family myself it's
great to hear a voice as unique and
keenly observed to Keith buss in showing
us these characters lives and struggles
it made me feel understood it spoke
clearly and with humor about what it's
like to be a part of something and yet
still be a part going forward we're all
eagerly anticipating during Ward Gita's
unique creative voice so today I'm very
pleased to present as a nickles fellow
yet the Malik
whoo that was awesome thank you so much
it was really cool to hear that okay I'm
so happy to be here I'd like to thank
everyone on the nickel committee and
Joan and Greg thank you all for this
incredible honor it's still surreal for
me to say that I'm an academy nickel
fellow a couple of years ago I only made
it as far as the top 10% and even then I
was like hell yeah
top 10% I was so excited it was just so
nice not to get a flat no a flat
rejection because believe me I've gotten
a lot of noes just years and years of
noes and more to come of course I'm sure
but even getting to that top 10% was
just the motivation I needed to keep
plugging away and now to actually have
won this fellowship is just the best
kind of validation for all those hours
spent wondering if I should have
listened to my mother and at least been
a part-time radiology technician because
they make steady money and I guess it's
dr. adjacent despite her worries about
my future my mother is still one of my
biggest champions and one of my biggest
inspirations especially for the script
dinner with friends as you heard it's
the story of a teenager whose mother
used to be a fiery feminist activist and
gave it all up to live one of those
lives of quiet desperation and through
her daughter's journey of self-discovery
she reclaims her own identity and
remembers her own strength and this is
such an incredibly personal story for me
it's all Indian people for one thing
people I grew up with and it's their
stories and it's my mother's story and
it's my own story since becoming a
mother myself and despite the heaviness
of the themes it is indeed a comedy
because that's the best way I know to
tell stories and that's my voice and
it's such a relief to know that people
are responding to that voice and to this
script because while it isn't
necessarily mainstream I do feel that is
universal okay I want to wrap up by
thanking the most important people in my
life my friends and family who never let
me give up who have always told me to
keep trying and whoever had countless
drafts who have been shoulders for me to
cry on and who have truly been full of
joy for even the smallest of my
successes my mother the brave and
intrepid explorer and my hero
I hope I better not cry my dear sister
and brother who have always listened to
my stories and laughed at my jokes even
when they were clearly not funny
my two sweet lunatic little daughters
Samira and Lila and last and most my
wonderful husband veggetti I wouldn't be
anywhere close to here without your love
and support and friendship so thank you
all I'm so grateful for this honor and I
hope to do all proud thank you